bonjour mes amis si aujourd'hui vous
avez envers envie de rire et bien je
vous conseille de vous chatouiller comme
ça à aa parce que moi je n'ai vraiment
pas le temps de vous amuser je dois
écrire une pièce de théâtre que ma
demande et mademoiselle séraphine la
maîtresse d'école il y a déjà une
semaine et je n'ai pas encore écrit le
premier mot
décidément je ne trouve rien rien je
n'ai aucune aspiration
au françois joly au secours au secours
hâtives pour moi c'est vraiment casimir
pourquoi je suis désespéré je n'arrive
pas à écrire la pièce de mademoiselle
séraphine fait des mois et des mois vous
allez aussi quelquefois oui on va
essayer casimir eux ou aller tu as bien
j'en suis au tout début l'on garde
des feuilles complètement blancherie en
effet casimir tonka et dramatique est
dramatique d'autant plus devoir écrire
une comédie bon et bien écoute va faire
à tour nous nous allons essayer de
travailler à temps que c'est à dire quel
est le titre de cette pièce si vous me
disiez ça me ferait bien plaisir hein si
vous le disiez ça me ferait bien plaisir
c'est un très joli titre up mais non ça
ce n'est pas un titre si vous me
trouviez un titre cela me ferait plaisir
à bon d'accord allez bon courage
merci
il s'agit maintenant de remplir sa
feuille blanche avec les répliques qui
lie pièce de théâtre écoute si nous
allions chacun de notre côté travailler
et et puis qu'après nous mettions nos
idées en commun chacun de notre côté
pour mettre ensuite nos idées en commun
c'est pas facile ça quand on va quand
même essayer alors du papier
voyons
voyons tout
j'ai lu je lis oui tu trouve quelque
chose bah rien du tout et toi rien de
rien à ma page blanche est devant moi là
elle me nargue dirait qu'elle me dit
t'es trop minable pour trouver quelque
chose d'intelligent écrire ben moi aussi
ça n'est pas facile du tout on attend
enfin le savons au moins qu'il faut que
ce soit drôle
c'est à dire
amusant
évidemment julie évidemment
au
général
très chère julie ce bon françois vous
préparez déjà carnaval
mais c'est ma vue ne m'abuse ce sont des
confettis et bien c'est à dire c'est
casimir qui nous avait demandé d'écrire
une pièce de théâtre pour lui il n'y a
pas la moindre petit dit eh
oui voila je vois il va falloir une fois
de plus que je vous tire d'affaires en
l'écrivant moi même ce petit chef
d'oeuvre fériés ça vous acceptez c'est
comme si c'était fait débat n'est pas
bien blanchi des faits similaires
[Applaudissements]
un stylo question reste ils ont eu à
stylo merci merci voilà stylo chaque
jour télé ma chère amy je suis drôle un
doux et drôle mes chers amis je ne peux
écrire que dans la solitude complète
puis j'en prends acte et votre culture
et bien sûr et il est vide je n'ai pas
eu le temps encore de l'orangé mais je
vous en prie et le monsieur du snop vous
avez besoin de quelque chose dont tout
va très bien investissements non au
centre var merci beaucoup courage à ces
nounous wiiware sur la
bourre alors
qu'est-ce que non
[Musique]
alors euh non ça non plus
à ça vient
je crois que ça vient
je suis je
et voilà mes chers amis vous pouvez dire
à casimir qui peut signer cette pièce de
son nom
[Musique]
à
et qu'est ce qu'il est mais que s'est-il
passé avec la pièce
monsieur du slam séraphine a pas plus
ici à lui a beaucoup plu mais elle m'a
dit que c'était un plagiat de molière
alors je n'ai pas osé lui demander ce
que ça voulait dire
casimir je reviens sur la tête merci
casimir faire un clin d'oeil à ces
prendre à son compte les idées d'un
autre et molière qui a vécu au 17e
siècle est un des plus grands auteurs du
théâtre français art monsieur les snobs
a dû copier une pièce de molière c'est
un plagiaire alors quelqu'un qui fait un
plagiat est un plagiaire oui exactement
alors monsieur le snob est un plagiaire
tu as parfaitement compris et bien je
vais allez m'expliquer sur la plage avec
ce plagiaire du snob et lui dire ce que
je pense de son plagiat
[Musique]